Okay, I wanna make something very clear here.
I do not hate Taylor Swift. Okay.
Right. I'm going to the eras to up
just to be completely transparent.
I will be there.
I'm a Gayla.
I'm a Kayla.
I'm a I'm a Swiftie.
Okay. I'm a Swiftie.
But here is the thing
and I've said it on here before and I'll say it again.
The most important thing we need to be able to do
as feminist when we raise our feminist consciousness
is we need to be able to hold
contradictions in our mind.
We need to be able to hold contradictions.
Being a woman in a patriarchy,
one of our biggest strength is to learn how to hold
contradictions.
I love pop music.
I love being a girly pop.
For me, that symbolizes so much in my life.
Like it symbolizes my freedom.
It symbolizes my ability
to just be a girl and be a girl's girl.
It symbolizes
I fuck you to all of my exes
who thought that they had better taste in music than me.
It symbolizes just joy and freedom
and clocking off and switching off
and just being able to enjoy something
for the sake of it.
Because my full time job is being a professional
feminist. I am
I have a doctor in feminism.
I run a feminist text startup.
I run a feminist consulting agency.
I run a feminist TikTok.
My full time job is being A feminist
and using my brain in that way.
So for me, being able to like
indulge myself in like
pop culture is like
genuinely something that feels like an indulgence
and something that I love to do
and something that's important for me
in my personal life
to be able to embrace completely
Taylor Swift.
And loving Taylor Swift
also symbolizes my relationship with my little sister
who has like
Taylor Swift is
like her special interest
and we've always connected over it.
And like we're going to the concert together
and it's just something that me and my sister just
are able to fully connect over.
And to me, that is like
very beautiful and very important.
Also, just think
being a Taylor Swift fan is so much fun.
And I often just feel like people who don't get it
are missing out
because it is just like
fun to be a part of this community. However,
we need to be able to freely hold
people in power to account
and we need to be able to love something.
Like you love Harry Potter,
but you can still critique JK.
Rowling or critique the books themselves,
like the podcast,
which please
does a really good job of that.
You can, you need to be able to like
fully love this
and you do this with love.
You're like,
I love this thing
and I care about this thing
and I can also critique this thing.
And those two things can both be true.
At once when you love and care for something,
you want it to work out.
You want it to be okay.
And I think
we need to be okay in this world.
Like things are complex.
We know so much.
We got just like
social media and globalization
and just like this crazy economy and these wars.
And like one of your best
tools in your tool belt
for still being able to enjoy life and
turn down your critical
dial and not let it all overwhelm you
and enjoy the things you love,
um, even if they're slightly problematic,
while also being able to analyze
and kind of critique
those things as well.
And knowing how to do those things at once is gonna be
like one of the most valuable
like intellectual tools in your toolkit for surviving
in what I feel is an increasingly apocalyptic
kinda world.
So that's what I think about that.